hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
going to explain a 2014 American fantasy
and action movie called Seventh Son
which follows the story of a master and
his Apprentice who fight off evil
otherworldly beings
high in the mountains Gregory imprisons
Malkin a powerful witch who is begging
him to release her years pass then she
regains his strength and power in a
blood moon
she escapes her imprisonment in Dragon
form in a village Bradley Gregory's
Apprentice seeks his master to inform
him that a village child is infected
Gregory replies that he deals with other
worldly beings no more but a knight
pushes him to fight Gregory refuses to
comply with the Arrogant Knight's order
then a brawl breaks out he skillfully
defeats the Knight then goes with
Bradley after he knows the Bells Are
Ringing which means he is summoned to
the Village the two go to the village
and find the little girl seeming
possessed turns out the evil spirit
Behind The Possession is Mother Malkin
whose strength has returned after
Gregory imprisoned her Bradley is almost
tempted by her beauty but he manages to
snap back and work with his master to
capture her unfortunately she attempts
to flee then when she is almost pushed
into a cage she drags Bradley with him
seeing he has no choice to save his
Apprentice Gregory burns the cage
however Malkin still has the strength to
escape in her Dragon form somewhere far
away There lives a peaceful family of
farmers Tom the Seventh Son loves to
hunt pigs and dreads getting out of his
boring Hometown Kate his sister yells at
him to tend the pigs then his body
suddenly shakes and he sees a vision
Kate calls their mother who seems to
know how to care for his son Master
Gregory then arrives at Ward's residence
on a boat he knows There lives a Seventh
Son of the Seventh Son a qualification
to become a knight like him and would
like to recruit him he explains he is in
a hurry and pays a lot of money to the
patriarch Tom recognizes Gregory as the
man from his Visions then agrees to
become his Apprentice before he leaves
mam Ward gives him her mysterious
pendant which she hid from Gregory when
she first greeted him meanwhile Malkin
arrives in her Fortress and questions
her sister Lizzie who is badly injured
from Gregory's doing
she heals her and rebuilds the wrecked
Fortress Lizzie explains that The Spook
Gregory has made them suffer
Gregory and Tom arrive in a town and
split up to gather Provisions Tom sees a
commotion finding an accused which who
is about to be executed
he recognizes the girl from his visions
and uses his position as Gregory's
Apprentice to deal with her after hiding
in an alley he frees her
she disappears without a trace turns out
she is Alice Lizzy's daughter a witch
spy who has been following Gregory
Gregory and Tom continue their Journey
they walk in a forest full of guts he
questions his master's former
apprentices who were all killed Gregory
talks about Bradley his best Apprentice
who was killed by Malkin they will head
to malkin's Fortress and Pendle Mountain
to stop her before her full-strength
returns and she will lay waste to cities
Tom suddenly has Visions again and
passes out he wakes up on a boat and
meets Tusk another companion of his
master they arrive at Gregory's
residence Tom asks about an old tapestry
of the Falcons an army of knights who
are powerful to fight darkness and
otherworldly beings and deduces that
Gregory is the only Falcon left as other
Knights have succumbed to Darkness
Gregory reminds him that they only have
a week before the red moon when Malkin
and her witches will gain their fullest
extent of power
before dismissing him Gregory tells Tom
not to get out of his Chambers he tests
him by activating one of the dark
creatures to make noise which disturbs
Tom he goes out to check the noise and
is immediately attacked by it Gregory
thinks Tom fails him but is impressed
when Tom throws a dagger that almost
hits him Tom begs Gregory to teach him
he then studies malkin's lieutenants and
learns gears and Potions used in
fighting witches meanwhile Malkin is met
by her lieutenants Radu brings her his
finest assassins
she intimidates them and murders one of
them who dares to look at her seeing
that Alice fears for her safety and asks
Lizzie if following Malkin is the right
thing to do Lizzy convinces her that it
is the right thing and that malkin's
powers will make men no longer Target
them to be burned
Alice then continues spying on Tom and
Gregory by intentionally bathing under
the Moonlight to attract Tom's attention
when they touch a blue spark emerges Tom
realizes Alice is a witch but does not
seem to hate her he even spills that he
and his master will be going to Pendle
Mountain to defeat Malkin Alice
disappears again
the next day Gregory is summoned to the
walled City delaying their journey to
Pendle Mountain he needs to deal with
urog the deadliest of malkin's
lieutenants he lets Tom finish the job
but he hesitates to burn him and decides
not to do it Gregory is disappointed
then leaves without him unbeknownst to
them Alice watches the commotion she
then approaches Tom again then they make
out Alice believes the blue spark
earlier is caused when two souls are
destined to meet Tom wants to get out
somewhere safe with her but she thinks
it is not possible he sees Visions again
of Malkin defeating Gregory then decides
to go back to his master to help him
Gregory admits to Tom that he fell in
love with Malkin once but she became
jealous after knowing he had a wife whom
she murdered he showed her Mercy by not
killing her and only imprisoning her but
that was a mistake meanwhile all
malkin's lieutenants except ugar have
gathered and they learn from Alice that
the two Spooks are approaching closer to
the Fortress they encounter Bogart a
reckless terrestrial giant with low
vision they fight but Gregory
misunderstands the opponent thinking it
fears water Tom finally defeats it after
they fall off a waterfall he then is
threatened by Lizzie but her sword
struck his pendant she is shocked
because she knows the pendant belongs to
Malkin then escapes
Tom shows the pendant to Gregory it is a
number in stone a powerful witch
Talisman that enhances their Illusions
it multiplies malkin's strength but was
stolen by another witch after that
Gregory was able to defeat her they
deduce ma'am Ward as a witch who stole
the pendant for Malkin which makes Tom a
witch while also being a spook
Apprentice meanwhile Lizzie informs
Malkin about Tom's feelings for Alice as
she sensed it when she encountered him
then Malkin instructs Alice to retrieve
the pendant from Tom if she succeeds
Malkin may consider sparing Tom's life
Malkin and her lieutenants then attacked
the village
they show their forces to avenge those
witches that the men have executed ma'am
Ward who happens to be in town defends
it despite warnings from her family
Malkin immediately realizes a witch is
betraying her and siding with the
Villagers then murders man Ward Gregory
Tom and Tusk continue their Journey
while Gregory and Tusk check on
something and leave Tom behind Alice
appears and approaches Tom Gregory and
Tusk quickly return Then capture Alice
Tom defends her believing that not all
witches are evil he frees her not
realizing she has stolen his pendant the
three then chase her to a forest where
malkin's Army awaits them a battle
ensues Tom and Tusk fall off a canyon
while Gregory is captured and then
brought to Malkin after regaining
Consciousness Tom meets with her
mother's Spirit who convinces him to
have courage except his powers and
defeat Malkin he finds Tusk who also
survived the fall and together they head
for Pendle Mountain meanwhile malkin's
lieutenants bring Gregory before her she
seduces him using the stone to enhance
her powers Alice is devastated when
learning that malkin's Army left Tom to
die then she interrupts her aunt and
takes off her pendant canceling her
Illusions and snapping Gregory back to
his senses Malkin chases after her but
Lizzie stands in her way defending her
daughter as she means everything to her
they transform into dragons and then
chase after each other meanwhile on the
ground a fight ensues between Alice Tom
and Gregory against malkin's Army Tom
finds Alice then she explains that she
took the pendant to supposedly make
Malkin spare his life
seeing the pendant Beneath The Fortress
ruins Tom claims his powers combining
The Spook staff with a pendant his power
easily defeats malkin's lieutenants
Malkin and Lizzy fight each other until
both are injured however Malkin gains
the upper hand in the end exclaiming
that she disapproves of her sister's
betrayal then murders her Gregory tells
Tom he must defeat Malkin alone and
enters the Fortress by himself he finds
Malkin lying on her bed who questions
his love for her he states that he
Harbors a love for her no more then
secretly wields a dagger to stab her but
she chokes him first from the door Tom
throws a dagger at Malkin fatally
injuring her he then finishes his job by
burning the witch on her bed ending her
reign of terror they then leave the
Fortress
sometimes later Gregory marks Tom's hand
with a falcon night Mark accepting him
to be a master Tom meets Alice again who
accepts that he chooses to fight evil
Powers instead of being with her he then
prepares to leave but learns in the end
that the horse he prepares is for
Gregory to ride while enjoying his
retirement
Gregory gives up his residence and all
his inheritance to Tom after seeing his
former Master ride off the Horizon Tom
hears a bell ringing and quickly
prepares to go on a mission
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching